[Music]
with dignity and respect
committed to free speech and
entertaining straight talking and direct
we may act eight each other and you
thought provoking provocative and
controversial hello and welcome to the
pledge now there are some pretty simple
rules when it comes to weddings dress
smartly turn up on time and do not under
any circumstances upstage the bride but
it seems nobody told the Prime Minister
this when she turned up for a break on
the Isle of Wight last weekend she
interrupted Michelle and Jason died
having a few photos taken to mark their
special day
fortunately the happy couple didn't mind
and missus may even stopped to have a
snap of them and tell them tell Michelle
how beautiful she looked as for Michelle
we've found her a gate-crashing prime
minister now I'm just got to find us
someone to marry her well there you got
this is maybe this one's coming back
stellar okay coming up nick says we need
to see and hear our leaders at elections
Michelle preaches to the choir about
education Rachel tackles the gig economy
and will give Greg a penny for his
thoughts but first it's me I want to
talk about immigration not whether it's
good or bad we've already done that
dance now we have to look forward and
how it's going to be post brigs it my
population has soared by nearly seven
million since 2001 largely because of
uncontrolled immigration and yes much of
it has been advantageous but the
downside is that millions of unskilled
workers have come here on road or
effectively slave wages and it's turned
us into a lazy nation and businesses
have let that happen because it's easier
to pay a romanian six pounds for an hour
to clean toilets than incentivize a Brit
with decent wages that has to change
post brexit immigration policy has to be
fairer to everyone forget a EU slave
labor and start training people already
here future immigration has to be
based on what our economy needs not
dictated by an EU cartel that doesn't
care what uncontrolled immigration does
to communities and our public services
and his policy forces us to favor its
laborers over skilled Indian doctors
post breaks that Britain can't be about
closing our doors it has to be about
flinging them wide open to the world and
show you picking only the people who
will make this country prosper Kara not
for the first time you're absolutely on
top of the news because you'll have seen
the migration Advisory Committee or
m.a.c report that talk exactly about
that and I think you'll agree
underscored a lot of your points yeah
there's something I want to raise with
you you said we've been turned into a
lazy nation we might explore that I
don't know if you can be turned into a
lazy nation and and where I'm definitely
with you is you go to an airport or you
go to a port and you see people from
countries such as Australia and New
Zealand South Africa who was shoulder to
shoulder with us in wars and there at
the back of the queue as Bulgarians and
I'm timid but let's look at something
that was on the Sophie Ridge on Sunday
show last Sunday with dr. Liam Fox who's
of course international trade secretary
well we have to end free movement we
have to end free movement to honor the
results of the referendum we voted to
have control of our borders we voted
tough control of our laws they voted
have control of our money and so we need
to see that that free movement is
brought to an end I think it's from from
the points I've been making to it's very
clear that it has its advantages not
just in terms of stopping public
services being used by those who haven't
contributed but can be an extra tool in
the box when it comes to future trade
negotiations with other countries Liam
Fox talking to Sophie Ridge Association
on Sunday here on Sky News that's my
problem
the last part there it could be an extra
tool in the box when it comes to future
trade negotiations with other countries
Carol you can't support the
weaponization of people effectively in
the brexit talks can you no I can't but
but can I go back to what you're saying
before about why I think it's made us a
lazy nation I think that people coming
into this country when I say they've
been turned into a slave army that's
exactly what I mean because the people
coming in from the either unskilled
workers obviously not the schools beyond
school they're doing the due
jobs that many Brits will not do when
they're there the Brits won't do them
because they're not paid enough and my
argument is stop all the unskilled
workers we don't need two million
builders in this country what we need is
skilled well we don't we need skilled
people and we know and we need yeah we
do but we don't need two million polish
walls we don't need you know millions
correct but what we do need is to use
the people already here to pay them
better wages to pay them the Brits
already here better wage we've seen the
way you know a lot of people are you
know on the Left who argue that we
should keep the doors open they can't be
happy about the fact that we have a lot
of workers in this country he'll come
here they're living in the most
appalling conditions tend to a room
they're on below average wages we've got
to stop that it's not fair it's not
right and we've got to pay the people
here who are not in work decent wages so
they will do weaponize people lastly
that is wrong what dr. Fox said on Sky
News is wrong isn't it using it as a
tool that's horribly immigrations yeah
in your bricks it's all that you have to
but you have to remember that the reason
a lot of people voted to leave the
European was because of immigration you
know we have to we have to tell me
coming up it is a sign immigration okay
which is the numbers of non-eu and au
March 2017 to March 2018 88,000 EU and
235 thousand non EU now I think this
m.a.c report has suggested that they
lift the cap on skilled non EU migration
in order to have a higher wage economy
but I'm very worried about just
privileged inge high-skilled workers
from whether it's from the non EU or the
EU because I genuinely think that we do
need to have plentiful migration we need
to have an open we need to be open for
business to have a functioning economy
can I just give you a couple of
statistics which is that it's not just
low skilled workers who are flooding the
market to do the jobs that Brits won't
do mop floors serving pret white bottoms
according to a YouGov poll ninety-seven
employees in hospitality would be unable
to work here under the you you know
you've got to be skilled
I cut near my glasses on 95 percent of
workers in transport and storage and
even in finance which you'd think would
be a high school they'd all be allowed
because they're earning over 30,000
pounds there's also going to be a cap as
well as a skills qualification for even
course enterprise can we really afford
to have all these people not working the
Mack report does say is that you know it
could have a short-term negative impact
but that would be ruled out by using the
people by paying the people we have here
already better wages saying these people
have to work they've got to take these
jobs you know on the dole and you're
claiming benefits and there are jobs out
there to have you should be made and
those jobs should be better pay the
let's take a there's a guy called Peter
stocking she wants a think tank just
ever look at what he says but on your
point if we look at Social Care there
are more than a hundred thousand
vacancies today today and what is
happening at the moment is the EU
low-skilled workers are filling lots of
those positions but if we stop those
from coming we're gonna face a massive
crisis in our sector we're looking at
around four hundred thousand unfilled
jobs in ten years time
now lots of your viewers will be
thinking well why don't we just get
bridge people to do it now the issue is
that if you ask the sector they say
we're just not paying high enough wages
to attract those British workers well
why don't we pay them all well the fact
is Social Care has got a massive funding
black hole today within a wider local
government black hole that's exactly
what I said paid people already but the
point is that does mean increasing
taxation all right because then in the
social care sector which is by and large
a public sector
why does it meet him so how do you go
ahead you buy does it mean increase how
do you pay them because for years have
got away with paying these are not slave
weight these are not businesses that
they're mainly in this Romania in the
public sector now are you gonna
therefore increase council tax are you
going to increase taxation I use any way
to pay them pop so you're saying instead
of a Romania
working one of these homes is connected
British there's no she's also saying
that you've only got you're only gonna
get the best to do it if you pay them
more and I agree with that I'm I'm all
for paying people to work in in those
sectors more money but you always want
to raise taxes no no it's so I'll say a
few things so first of all when I was a
teenager I got a job in a pub kitchen
when I was 16 my siblings used to do
fruit picking they used to get picked up
in a mini-boss and they used to go off
and they used to go at the various
different phones and then you to do
picking and there used to earn a lot
more money for me so there so they wear
Brits that was willing to do those jobs
I'm not saying that they relish the
opportunity of that but they used to do
those jobs cuz they want that cash
there's those kids probably wouldn't do
that work anymore because the wage has
been suppressed it's been suppressed
because oh thank you so that's the first
point the second point is we are able to
exert various different controls and
we've always chosen not to so will you
go back to 2004 and you looked at when
we was talking about Eastern Europeans
and adding those to the EU we could of
put transitional controls in like most
countries in the EU decided not to and
in the third point I was met I would
make is it's not just about business
because I would ask anyone around this
table if you was doing renovations in
your own house and you needed some I
don't know an extension building and
you've got a quote from a Polish builder
for I don't know I'm being silly with my
figures for 10 grand or you've got a
quote from a British builder for 20
grand sorry but most people here wait
would you let me say this what do you
choose the ten thousand pound polish
materiality but that's what drives down
wages folk for people who are builders
and that's what's not fair and that's
actually what's got to stop and you know
we have to stop talking about you know
this guy's talking about Social Care in
the National Health Service let's stop
pretending that if we stop two hundred
three hundred thousand people are coming
here that the Health Service is gonna
form no it's not the Health Service
employs 1.5 million people all that 1.5
million let me finish this one pie are
we 5.6 percent or au nationals that
amounts to 66 thousand people it's not
gonna fall if you're talking about
Social Care he wasn't talking about
is also